we have a voicemail number that number
is a two one nine two david p a caller
says that there is something more boring
than nascar that caller is the Eggman
and he says that it's the world cop take
a listen to this game i can't believe it
you just said how boring NASCAR is
mind-numbingly boring i totally agree
it's absolutely boring the worst thing
to watch however the only thing more
boring then watching NASCAR is watching
world cup soccer people kick it around
the ball four to five two hours to get
one goal boring boring oh my god how can
you think NASCAR is boring but thinking
world cup soccer is exciting oh my god
David they're equally horrible or
fiction even because it is sports they
should be considered bleep age alone
brother I don't know that I've ever
disagreed more with the egg man than
here there is no similarity between
World Cup soccer and NASCAR the idea
that World Cup soccer listen yeah I
don't even know if I should bother
because if you don't get why World Cup
soccer is exciting and one of the best
sporting events that there is period on
our planet and you think it's equal to
NASCAR in any way there's nothing I can
say to convince you otherwise right
that's just it is beyond it's a cultural
thing it's beyond me the egg man is
going to space so much blowback because
while in the u.s. here I mean we pretend
to care about soccer every four years
turbos Cup comes around in other
countries soccer is a religion and you
can expect the egg man to hear from some
people a soccer is a religion and NASCAR
is a laughingstock in other countries
let NASCAR is a literal laughingstock
people see that and they say what is
wrong with people that they would watch
that and I agree with that view
call me anti-american if you want mean
people already do right what's the big
deal we've got a great bonus show for
you today get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member or patron thanks
for watching thanks for listening will
talk to you then